l'allemagne elle accélère son
déconfinement un projet d'accord entre
la chancelière angela merkel et les
présidents de région était formellement
adopté hier le texte lève la
quasi-totalité des restrictions toutes
les écoles vont pouvoir ouvrir à
condition de respecter les mesures
d'hygiène
idem pour les commerces et le
championnat allemand de foot qui reprend
ses droits le 15 mai réactions partagées
outre-rhin
comme nous avons plusieurs magasins
c'était un temps très difficiles un
temps très dur financièrement mais aussi
vis-à-vis des salariés on ne savions pas
si ça allait continuer oui ou non mais
nous étions très heureux quand nous
avons eu l'information de pouvoir ouvrir
le confinement peut fonctionner avec un
masque et une distance absolument
mais malheureusement pas tous nos
châssis tient surtout dans les magasins
c'est très serré on est bousculé nous
avons fermé le 17 mars nous le devions à
cause de la situation et cela a fait mal
à nos finances nous serions contents si
dans une ou deux semaines nous pouvions
de nouveau ouvrir tout doucement
par exemple si nous pouvons déjà remplir
la moitié de notre resteront de notre
terrasse
cela nous arrangerait beau